[Musique]
il a plu tout à l'heure l'odeur de la
terre mouillée se mêlent aux parfums des
troènes et qui allait des acacias là-bas
des petites filles font une ronde un peu
de boue sur leurs mollets un peu de
confiture sur leurs joues leur chance on
pénètre par les fenêtres ouvertes c'est
le printemps au village
belleville et ménilmontant les quartiers
les plus campagnard de paris
présenteront bientôt un aspect
absolument différent
[Musique]
qui a vécu ici dans cette maison pareil
à un bateau échoué la dernière voiture
de déménagement s'en est allée avec sa
cargaison de meubles boiteux et de
plantes vertes anémique un chat oublier
air au milieu des pièces vides bientôt
le décor n'existera plus que dans le
souvenir de quelques-uns
[Applaudissements]
à
ma famille
m
aux environs de l'actuelle église se
situer le coeur de l'ancien petit bourg
il possédait déjà son artère principale
la rue de belleville que board est alors
des guinguettes
[Musique]
pendant longtemps chaque année le soir
de mardi gras le tout paris monte à son
l aiea bellerive
le roi de la fête c'était mieux en mars
ou y au petit matin les pierrots les
paillasses les colombines envahissent et
tous les véhicules disponibles afin de
rejoindre paris tout au long du parcours
les fenêtres se louer plusieurs mois al
avance
le boeuf rouge le tambour royal la
carotte filandreuse le cabaret des
noyers ne sont pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les guinguettes d'autres fois il ne
reste rien pas même un arm pas même une
peine elle
[Musique]
l'ancien théâtre de belleville lui aussi
a disparu
[Musique]
c'est à belleville et ménilmontant que
l'on trouvait jadis la plus forte
proportion de parisiens authentique ils
étaient des gens humbles ouvriers de
fabrique artisans isolé de paris par la
verte frontières d'un parc
d'un côté c'était la ville de l'autre un
univers de maisons bars un jardinet
paradis dominicaux
de l'autre côté des vite une église
inchangé les boutiques on repart leur
façade mais les rues gardent leur aspect
provincial et vieillot
[Musique]
1900 le grand oiseau inhabituel
événements inquiétants survole les
promenades familiales passe la semaine
vient le dimanche les mois s'écoulent et
se bousculent les années
la jeunesse c'était hier
[Musique]
un détail touchent parfois au coeur le
promeneur et lui permet d'imaginer
d'autres temps les images se superposent
sur les maisons d'aujourd'hui à paris
tout un univers de jardin du vivante
d'arbres fruitiers de vignes de tonel le
bas de la colline
c'était autrefois le domaine des
ouvriers si l'on montait la côte le
paysage se transforme et les fruits et
les légumes pousser dans cet endroit où
aujourd'hui on les vend le plateau
appartenait à une population sage et
paisible de jardiniers et deviendront le
lait que l'on buvait venait des vaches
de la ferme voisine les vendanges se
faisait en chantant les maisons en
automne embaumer les confitures
[Musique]
il reste encore çà et là des boutiques
aux façades démodé et charmante elle dit
niant les éclairages au néon et les
ravages de la matière plastique et pour
combien de temps pour combien de temps
encore
[Musique]
le
m
à chaque printemps les jardins
sauvegarde et s'habille de lilas à la
sab le mans dans l'ombre paradisiaque
des portes cochères les amoureux
s'embrassent bousculer parfois par des
enfants qui se poursuivent en criant aux
bords des fenêtres des chats s'étire
tout soleil
[Musique]
oh
et
quand le soir vient les travailleurs
remonte à l'assaut de leur village c'est
s'ouvrir en appartement ces usagers
blasé de gaz et de l'électricité
tourner un robinet pour se rafraîchir à
un peu habitants de belleville savez
vous que vous vivez en un lieu qui fut
longtemps le paradis des réseaux
ce sont les moines qui au 12e siècle
pensez à canaliser les eaux de
ruissellement afin de les diriger
jusqu'à leurs maisons de paris
[Musique]
le regard de la lanterne constitue la
tête de l'aqueduc de belleville il resta
pendant longtemps isolée dans la
campagne au milieu des champs et des
jardins au bout desquels tourner les
ailes des moulins à vent
belleville comme montmartre posséder ce
meunier
[Musique]
le célèbre baron haussmann lui-même
s'intéressa à belleville ce quartier
alors un peu retirée du doigt le parc
des buttes chaumont et ulla jusqu'en
1865 des carrières de plâtre accidenté
et pittoresque le paysage a changé il
s'est enrichi de fo se ruine de roches
et d'arbres
[Musique]
oh
non
lorsque le parc des buttes chaumont fut
trouvée au public paris sort des lycées
d'une ligne de chemin de fer tout neuf
la petite ceinture les gars pareilles à
celles avec lesquelles jouèrent les
premiers bénéficiaires des trains
miniatures nos arrière grands parents
sont toujours là dix souhaitent des
chars mende et dont les plates d'émail
et cahiers porte glorieusement des noms
de quartiers
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
il y a encore ici des coins secrets les
poules picorent des lapins qui se gavent
de carottes entre le passé et l'avenir
belleville et ménilmontant rift à 1h
transitoire et de futurs citadins se
fabriquent la des souvenirs d'enfance
villageois
[Musique]
à ma famille
harry longtemps s'est obstiné à le
conquérir que les plaines voici
maintenant qui montent à l'assaut des
collines un décor s'efface un autre des
cornées c'est la loi de la vie à dieu
village
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]